[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous
il y a tout juste un siècle le 11
novembre 1918 l'armistice était signé
mettant ainsi fin à la première guerre
mondiale avec nous pour évoquer cette
grande guerre en france en franche comté
et puis surtout ses conséquences trois
invités tout d'abord jean louis
bruguière créateurs et conservateur du
musée de la mémoire et de la paix qui se
trouve à clerval odile roanne est
maîtresse de conférences en histoire
contemporaine à l'université de
bourgogne franche comté et puis jean
michel blanchot qui est professeur
d'histoire
n'oubliez pas vous pouvez réagir à cette
émission sur twitter grâce au hashtag
dit mme paul fc comme dimanche en
politique franche comté alors on ne peut
pas ne pas en parler la polémique peta
emmanuel macron avait annoncé un hommage
à 8 maréchaux de la grande guerre dont
philippe pétain qui a collaboré avec les
allemands les nazis durant la seconde
guerre mondiale en 1945 pétain est
condamné à la peine de mort mais elle
n'est pas appliquée en raison de son
grand âge
le général de gaulle la commue en eau
l'emprisonnement à perpétuité
alors est-ce que emmanuel macron a fait
une erreur
et bien la réponse est en deux temps
d'abord on peut parler à tout le moins
d'une maladresse sinon même d'une erreur
dans la mesure où cette au fond cet
hommage aux à 8,8 des maréchaux donc aux
invalides et d'une dans une certaine
mesure un contresens sur le sens de la
commémoration sur le sens de cette date
du 11 novembre 2010 800 ans après donc
la fin de ce carnage au fond les vrais
héros de cette guerre ce sont les
soldats les l'immense majorité de ces
hommes et non pas quelques quelques
chefs militaires qui par ailleurs ne
n'ont pas forcément démérité c'est le
deuxième point
pétain effectivement il ya si vous
voulez c'est la deuxième dimension c'est
que s'il n'y a pas d'erreur sur le plan
historique lorsque macron dit que au
fond
pétain a été un grand soldat et bien sur
le plan moral on ne peut plus
aujourd'hui en 2018 parler évidemment de
pétain comme ça puisque nous savons à
quel point il sa responsabilité est
terriblement totalement et complètement
engagé dès mai juin 1940 jean michel
blanchot or le terrain mémorielle et
souvent glissant pour les hommes
politiques et là on a assisté à une
belle sortie de route donc maladresse ou
pas c'est difficile de trancher ce que
je dirais c'est que on de n'attend pas
du président de la république qui sont
un professeur d'histoire et qu'il
distingue le pétain qui va de verdun à
montoir ou au vel d'hiv
on attend du président de la république
d'incarner la mémoire nationale et
collective
et en ce sens là il ya sans doute à mon
sens une finir une erreur de perspective
on revient à la grande guerre avec eux
quelques chiffres qui font froid dans le
dos en franche comté il ya eu peu de
combat sur notre sol si ce n'est dans le
territoire de belfort et notamment à
joncherey mais cette grande guerre a tué
plus de trente cinq mille soldats en
franche comté
je voulais se découvrir le nombre de
morts département par département 35
mille soldats ont été tués durant les
cinq années de guerre
jean louis bruguière on va commencer
avec la photo d'un homme ce n'est pas
n'importe qui pour vous c'est votre
papier marius donc marius était votre
grand père il a fait la guerre de 14 18
dans les tranchées qu'est ce qui vous a
raconté sur sa guerre rapidement parce
qu'on a qu'une demi heure d'émission et
je pense que vous auriez beaucoup de
choses à raconter
alors le grand père s'appelait marius eu
lieu tôt ou né à toulon il est parti en
1912 elle est rentrée en 1911 1919 chez
lui donc il a bien fait certes ramené de
guerre il était incorporé deux ans avant
la guerre et puis il a fallu encore
plusieurs mois pour pour rentrer chez
lui quand qu'est ce qui vous a raconté
sur la vie dans les tranchées ont la vie
dans les tranchées déjà il est blessé
deux fois un coup de baïonnette et des
éclats de grenade dans les jambes et les
pieds jolie alors il a ce qui m'a
le plus marqué c'est quand il m'arrive
me dit il me dit à un moment donné la
peur que j'avais c'est quand on monte à
l'assaut des deux blessés est de ne pas
être secourues de rester blessés de se
rappeler le no man's land entre les
zones ya exactement reste le grand père
me racontait que plusieurs fois il
assistait à ça les prenons a eu un jour
une nuit on entendait râler les copains
je ne pouvais pas les secourir est-ce
qu'on allait certes eu aussi exactement
et pendant trois jours hexagone ise et
après c'était l'amour ça a été une
période très dure pour lui surtout pour
le moral
il a surtout aussi souffert du froid de
la fin et surtout les mauvaises
conditions avec on peut pas s'imaginer
est ce qu'ils ont pu souffrir au niveau
avec les rats avec la puanteur la
pourriture décor on n'arrive pas à se
mettre
c'est à dire qu'on a pas mal d'élèves ni
de nos musées mais pour raconter ça il
faut avoir vécu heureux et que les
témoins vous là vous mais je transmets
aux élèves de troisième qui viennent
nous visiter au diwan êtes vous aussi
vous ou l'un de vos grands pères a fait
14 18 il vous a raconté aussi des choses
très difficiles à entendre
oui mon grand père paternel tu es né en
1896 et en fait il
il rentre au service militaire au
printemps 1914 il est donc ap en fait
par la guerre alors qu'il a 18 ans une
guerre qu'il fera en totalité à laquelle
il survivra même s'il est blessé à deux
reprises en fait et bien sûr le contact
que j'ai eu avec lui jusqu'à l'âge de 17
ans puisqu'il est mort en 1984 m'a
beaucoup marqué parce que ça avait été
très probablement l'événement fondateur
dans sa ville l'événement le plus
marquant
celui aussi qui a déterminé une série de
choix par la suite un et notamment la
question de son engagement dans la
résistance pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale de nombreux événements
manifestations commémoration en tout
genre sont prévues durant ce moment
justement en mémoire de ces poilus morts
ou disparus
durant la première guerre mondiale alors
exemple d'une initiative intéressante on
va à pontarlier les élèves du collège
andré malraux sortent un livre dans
lequel se trouvent les biographies des
soldats de la ville et des villages
environnement environnants qui sont
morts durant cette période nous les
avons rencontrés ces élèves et voici ce
qu'ils disent de la première guerre
mondiale
qu'est ce que ça t'a apporté travailler
sur 14 18 a du respect pour les soldats
qui sont morts pour nous pour la france
j'ai trouvé que c'était horrible ben oui
je trouve ça pas normal qu'on est et
jean vivre comme ça avec des poudres à
la saleté
je m'attendais pas ce que les gens
meurent autant en fait à la chaîne
d'avoir travaillé dessus c'est pour nous
rendre compte que ça fait une guerre et
pour éviter de recommencer maintenant
les armes plus développer l'armé
nucléaire et tout et ça peut tuer tout
le monde dirait ça c'est pire
ça m'a apporté de prendre conscience de
l'importance de la guerre surtout pas de
l'horreur que c'était et que j'ai pas
envie de vivre ça au petit à la
gaillette y va pas non j'ai pas envie je
pense surtout que si la guerre
l'humanité va être détruite
[Musique]
jean louis bruguière est ce que vous
retrouvez la dans ses réflexions ce que
disent les jeunes dans votre musée à
clerval je précise juste je fais une
petite parenthèse pour les moins de 18
ans l'entrée gratuite dans votre musée
est-ce que vous retrouvez ce qu'ils
disent mais tout à fait on retrouve tout
à fait de ce que peuvent raconter ces
jeunes en venant puisé ces choses là
dans le musée il ya même certaines
photos que vous montrez pas à certains
enfants notamment ceux du riz mais
est-ce que c'est trop difficile
notamment les gueules cassées c'est trop
dur un des gueules cassées c'est sûr que
c'est pas évident à montrer et d'hommes
et à d'autres photos aussi qu' on ne
peut pas ne pas montrer ça disons que
les classes de 3e on peut quand même
parler un peu plus franchement et là
c'est vrai que quand ils s'en vont il y
en a plusieurs qui ont larme à l'oeil
certaines des filles et qui sentent même
pas bien jean-michel blanche où on a vu
donc que jean louis boujard et odile
roynette ont vu des témoins directs de
cette période
avoir des témoins directs maintenant il
y en a plus c'est une vision partielle
et partiale de l'histoire
mais ce que c'est vraiment très
important qu'on ait pu garder tous ces
témoignages c'est certain ça concourt
une meilleure compréhension des
événements envie effectivement comment
on le voit bien les élèves sont très
sensibles à ce sujet est ce que vous
sentez aussi vous c'est un sujet pour
dire les choses qui passent bien où le
parti des progrès des parties du
programme qui passe bien et les élèves
sont toujours très sensible cette notion
de tueries de masse cette notion de
seuil de violence ça effectivement ça
percute beaucoup chez les jeunes oui
alors l'après-guerre maintenant on est
en 1918 il y a eu 1,4 cent mille morts
un million quatre cent mille morts un
français il y a des blessés des
invalides des gaz et qu'est ce que ça
vous apporte dans la société française
justement cette période qui a été
terrible notamment dans les familles où
les femmes ont dû remplacer les hommes
partis au front alors on vient de le
dire par par différents biais l'aller
la société française les sociétés
belligérantes plus largement sont
totalement bouleversée par cette épreuve
est évidemment le retour un la
démobilisation des combattants et le
retour dans les familles des hommes qui
sont souvent très diminuée très affecté
sur le plan physique et sur le plan
psychique a été aussi une épreuve
importante pour ces hommes là mais aussi
pour ces femmes des femmes qui par
ailleurs avait investi de manière
importante l'espace public pendant la
première guerre mondiale puisqu'elles
sont été parfois d'ailleurs un petit peu
contrainte de même beaucoup contraintes
de travail et pris la place des hommes
dans les fermes pas réglable danger nos
erreurs je comptais cet éclair quoi
absolument et du coup elles ont assumé
des double tâche elles ont elles ont eu
un travail considérable elles ont assumé
des responsabilités considérables
pendant ces quatre années de guerre et
pour un certain nombre d'entre elles
notamment pour les femmes qui
travaillaient dans les usines ou qui
travaillait dans un certain nombre
d'administrations elles sont sommés par
une série de lois donc la première le 13
novembre 1918 de rentrer à la maison de
retrouver leur et la zone une espèce de
deux périodes où on leur demandait de
faire le travail d'un homme mais quand
les hommes reviennent il faut qu'elle
rentre à la maison s'occuper des enfants
de la cuisine
voilà en gros on peut on peut donc il ya
une schématique mais ces voix là il ya
une démobilisation très brutale des
femmes où l'on voit quand même que
l'autorité parentale partagée avec la
femme date de cette époque là alors ça
c'est une sas est une effectivement une
des avancées tout à fait considérable
qui a lieu pendant la première guerre
mondiale c'est à dire qu'en raison de la
mort de masse en raison aussi de la
mutilation extrêmement grave que subit
un certain nombre d'hommes le l'état en
fait autorise le transfert de l'autorité
parentale à la mer en cas de décès du
combattant ou en cas d'invalidité très
importante
par conséquent les femmes alors qu'elles
n'avaient pas cette autorité parentale
vont être
investie d'un rôle et d'une
reconnaissance d'un voilà d'une place et
elle n'avait pas il faudra attendre 1970
pour le partage réel de l'autorité de
l'autorité et puis aussi très paradoxale
la loi sur l'avortement est très
renforcée et l'avortement et réduit
après 14 18 alors en fait c'est par le
sait on le sait - oui c'est pas c'est
pas si paradoxal que ça c'est à dire que
les historiens ont bien montré qu'il ya
une forme de pousser du virilisme dans
la france de l'après guerre puisqu'il
s'agit au fond de restaurer d'une
certaine manière
lee dans une identité masculine et des
rôles masculins après la guerre et par
conséquent aussi la surveillance de la
conduite privée des femmes est renforcée
et le contrôle sur l'avortement contrôle
sur l'avortement notamment des femmes de
mobiliser et des veuves est très
important et en 1923
une loi est adoptée qui correctionnalisé
l'avortement c'est maintenant il faut
aller aux tribunaux fin voilà elle passe
devant la justice elle passe surtout
devant les tribunaux correctionnels ce
qui est en fait une mesure qui a
contribué à aggraver le poids des
sanctions qui ont pesé sur l donc
l'avortement est réprimée de manière
beaucoup plus dur dans
l'entre-deux-guerres qu'il ne l'était en
fait avant 1914 la rooney vous nous
parler des années 20 les années 20 sont
caractérisés par une chose c'est la
construction des monuments aux morts il
y en a pratiquement dans toutes les
communes de france
à quoi ça sert alors dès le départ le
monument aux morts ça sert à faire
mémoire c'est un lieu de mémoire donc il
s'agit de commémorer donc de rappeler le
souvenir de la perte d'un virgule 4
millions de français donc ça c'est la
première mission est donc en quelque
sorte et monuments mort c'est une sorte
de métaphore du deuil faut pas oublier
le contexte de la jeunesse de ses
monuments aux morts on a
environ 1 mort par tranche de 28
habitants
donc ça veut dire que la mort est
omniprésente dans la société de
l'immédiate après-guerre et les
monuments aux morts ont cette fonction
de rappeler ce sacrifice et pour le
pouvoir politique il s'agit de donner
sens à la mort d'un million 400 mille
soldats et donc il y a une dimension
civique et républicaine donc des morts
pour la france pour vraiment justifié ce
sacrifice
les anciens combattants ils n'ont pas
tout à fait la même lecture de va
demander à jean louis bruguière votre
grand père il allait au commémoration au
monument aux morts ou pas jean-louis
nanou plenel ou paie jamais jamais
jamais une
jamais une fille était tout le temps
tout le temps et qu'est ce qu'ils y
trouvaient lui d'après vous lui s'il se
souvenait de ce qu'il est ce qui s'était
passé sur ces quatre années et des
années terribles et chaque fois qu'ils
revenaient bon pendant deux jours ils
étaient n'était pas bien là ça n'allait
pas pour l'ancien combattant c'est le
monument aux morts est plus un tombeau
aucun hôtel de la patrie et il a une
notion de transmission de la mémoire
c'est l'ancien combattant de la
génération du feu veut faire devoir de
mémoire avant que le mot même de devoir
de mémoire n'existe et puisque aussi ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on fait on
parle vous dites de l'état la république
la nation
mais c'est aussi les gens qui financent
ces monuments aux morts
c'est pas l'état qui va financer dans
les 36000 communes de france un
engouement populaire est absolument
extrêmes et c'est pas effectivement
l'état qui a financé ce sont des
souscriptions publiques on sait bien que
dans le haut doubs on n'a pas hésité à
vendre plus de bois pour financer les
coupes d'aller fort exactement des très
beaux monuments de fait et donc on a une
opération de construction monumentale et
civique absolument inégalée complètement
inédite 36000 monument je crois qu'il ya
à peine 5
une dizaine de communes qui n'a pas de
monument en france et si on multiplie
par le nombre de plaques commémoratives
il faudrait multiplié par quatre le
nombre de monuments aux morts de
souvenirs en tout cas c'est absolument
impressionnant et ce qui est intéressant
aussi puisqu'on fait une émission en
franche comté c'est de signaler que par
exemple dans les régions très catholique
comme le oud ou sur les monuments aux
morts et on voit en ce moment des des
photos de pascal sur russia sur les
monuments aux morts il ya des symboles
religieux qu'on trouve pas dans le reste
de la région
voilà donc là ils se sont adaptés à la
réalité locale si j'ose dire donc vous
allez trouver effectivement des gènes
d'arc ou commun damprichard à saint
michel qui trône sur le bisc oui autre
chose également j'aimerais qu'on parle
du français la langue française dont on
va revenir après sur sur les
commémorations mais la langue française
c'est aussi l'un des grands changements
de cette période à savoir que par
exemple il franc comtois qui partait
dans les tranchées il parlait le patois
de leur région mais que dans les
tranchées c'est le français qui va
s'imposer
oui c'est à dire que la la grande guerre
a été aussi un événement de langage dans
le sens où elle a contribué à diffuser
les usages de la langue nationale à la
fois à l'oral et à l'écrit
alors évidemment on a en tant
qu'historien beaucoup plus de matériaux
on a même que des matériaux il écrit
donc on travaille sur les
correspondances de notamment de ce que
les linguistes appellent les peu les
traits c'est à dire ceux qui au fond se
débrouille avec le français qu'ils ont
appris à l'école primaire mais qu'ils
ont parfois un peu oubliée entre 13 13
ans et l'âge adulte et l'expérience de
la guerre l'expérience de la séparation
pour les couples notamment pour les
familles fait que chacun reprend les
cris une écriture et que nous dans les
académiques inviolable et surtout chacun
ses cris et tous les témoignages que
nous avons prouve que chacun ses cris
très majoritairement français et que
vous avez vous êtes par exemple retrouvé
des lettres de delphine pergaud qui est
la femme de louis pergaud l'auteur de la
guerre des boutons et qui était de
landresse à côté de besançon qui va
mourir qui va perdre la vie en 14 18
sont des lettres paraît-il très belle
magnifique lettre
qui sont donc qui ont été évidemment
conserver malheureusement nous n'avons
pas les réponses
voilà nous avons les lettres quelques
lettres et notamment la dernière lettre
que delphine pergaud a écrit à ses amis
martin est le 10 avril 1915
alors qu'elle ne sait pas encore que
louis pergaud est mort osez par ge dans
la meuse entre le 7 et le 8 et cette
lettre elle l est elle raconte en
reviens je reviens à ce qu'on ce qu'on
disait sur les femmes
elle raconte l'expérience de de l'
angoisse permanente dans laquelle les
femmes vivaient par rapport à la longue
possible de la mort ou de la blessure de
l'être aimé
et donc c'est à l'europe par ailleurs
delphine pergaud était quelqu'un de
lettrés oui donc écrivait dans un
français absolument parfait tout comme
évidemment louer pergaud mais dans les
correspondances de peu les traits on
voit les français bricoler avec avec la
langue et s'approprier davantage encore
que avec le conflit
cette chanson il ya un argot des
tranchées qui existent vous en avait
d'ailleurs fait un livre où il ya
certains mots qui sont passés dans le
langage populaire et qui date qui ont
été popularisées à ce moment là comme
lesquelles par exemple roche pourrait
prendre quelques exemples comme
des démos par exemple comme comme la
nouba faire la nouba qui vient par
exemple de l'armée de leur faire du
ramdam qui vient d'une contraction une
et surtout une transformation du mot
ramadan ou bien toubib qui désigne en
fait est dérivé d'un mot arabe qui
désigne le médecin voilà sont des
exemples ou bien encore aussi des
emprunts ou langues étrangères par
exemple tank lisa va rester et voilà la
difficulté un néologisme de cette époque
et un emprunt à la langue anglaise
voilà est-ce que l'exemple est ce que
l'on peut dire jean louis bruguière que
vous avez ouvert votre musée à clerval
en 1990 en hommage à votre grand père
poilus oui il y est pour beaucoup de
choses oui oui alors le musée moi
j'avais collectionner pas mal de choses
et j'ai voulu le mettre un exposition el
doctor crétins maire de clerval a
proposé une salle
et puis des finances et le fil en
aiguille on a pu construire ce musée et
c'est un musée qui s'appelle de la
mémoire et de de la paix et de la paix
il a déjà tout un tout un programme
revenons en mille ans en 2018 il y a
énormément de commémorations autour de
ce jour du 11 novembre
aujourd'hui un siècle plus tard comment
expliquer ce besoin de commémoration moi
je pense qu'une vraie passion 14 18 ans
chez les français alors ça peut
s'expliquer par la charge émotionnelle
qu'on retrouve dans toutes les familles
parce que de très nombreuses familles de
français ont une fille d'un mode famille
à l'horizon d'un grand oncle qui sont
morts pendant le conflit
donc chaque famille à un ou plusieurs
morts chaque famille retrouve des
photographies des lettres des souvenirs
donc ça doit sans doute alimenter cette
charge émotionnelle autour du conflit
oui et puis on voit derrière nous par
exemple d'aider y tombe qui sont
entretenues par le souvenir français
dans plusieurs cimetières militaires ou
civils est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer parce que vous en faites
partie du souvenir français
à quoi ça sert justement de coquines le
souvenir français et de continuer
d'entretenir les tombes des poilus donc
là il ya une dimension qui
de transmission de cette d'abord il ya
une jeune fille à qui nous le disait
tout à l'heure dans les interviews
ce que j'ai appris déjà par rapport à
14,18 c'est d'avoir du respect pour ses
soldats absolument et c'est la mission
première du souvenir français qui a été
créé avant la première guerre mondiale
que d'entretenir les sépultures des
soldats morts pour la france donc ça ça
fait partie de notre mission souvenir
français oui vous sentez vous cet
engouement autour de 14 18
oui oui surtout les surtout pour les
élèves les élèves qui viennent me voir
on voit cette année ils prennent
conscience de ce qu'il dit et ce qui
s'est passé elle est professeur qui nous
les amènent chez nous au musée vont dans
ce sens là et c'est une bonne chose que
ces jeunes qui viennent ici voit un peu
ce que leurs aînés ou fait et si on est
libre aujourd'hui c'est grâce à lui
la commémoration vous regarder ça avec
quel oeil vous qui est historienne mais
je crois qu'il ya un immense besoin de
comprendre encore s'entend après on sait
pas tout ce qui d'ailleurs pas seul j'ai
donné des chiffres de morts et disparus
mais on rajoute sur les monuments aux
morts tous les ans des des noms et on en
apprend davantage bien sûr et on
retrouve encore aujourd'hui des corps
qu'on est con on cherche à identifier
des corps qui sont des corps français
parfois mais qui sont aussi des corps
parfois qui viennent du 2
voilà deux familles du monde entier de
sun l'a par exemple du commonwealth qui
continuent à être identifié donc il ya
un immense besoin de compréhension et en
même temps ce qui m'a frappé aussi dans
les images tout à l'heure et dans ce
reportage sur ces jeunes de pompe à
pontarlier
c'est l'écart la difficulté à comprendre
la mort à la guerre c'est à dire que
c'est devenu quelque chose de très très
très loin de leurs jours aujourd'hui
c'est réservé à des professionnels
réservé aux militaires et ce ne sont
plus les jeunes pour la circonstance la
commet le coton on demande aux jeunes
appelés d'aller sous les drapeaux c'est
tout le peuple
la part dont la conscription la
conscription voilà oui c'est ça aussi
qui fait l'écart c'est vrai qu'on est
dans une armée professionnaliser
aujourd'hui qu'il est bon qui peut qui
pourra d'ailleurs qui peut évoluer de ce
point de vue là mais en tout cas
effectivement l'écart s'est un petit peu
creusé d'ailleurs d'où l'importance
injustement de du travail mémoriel et
aussi ce que je voulais dire c'est que
là on a assisté depuis plus de quatre
ans un travail immense de la part des
historiens et à un investissement
collectif notamment en france autour de
la commémoration autour par exemple de
deux initiatives comme la grande
collecte où il fallait voilà nos
archives l'ailé les objets je voulais
juste vous demander leurs 14 18 hormis
cela par la polémique macron pétain et
ses 14 18 ça fait consensus
le 11 novembre ça n'a pas toujours été
le cas y compris chez nous en franche
comté
loin s'en faut le 11 novembre a toujours
été émaillées de divers incidents des
anciens combattants parfois boycotter le
11 novembre
en franche comté on a le souvenir d'un
11 novembre plus politisé en 1968 quand
on était distribué des tracts anti
militariste l'armée pour quoi faire ou à
belfort en 1974 quand il ya une
manifestation devant les casernes de
belfort donc aujourd'hui c'est 11
novembre ou une commémoration un petit
peu aseptisé consensuel mais ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas
oui et et vous expliquer comment que ce
soit pacifié ici je vais employer ce
terme
après je pense qu'il ya peut-être aussi
il faut prendre faut faire attention à
ne pas avoir un
une mauvaise perspective de ce débat des
commémorations parce qu'aujourd'hui on
insiste beaucoup dans le grand public
sur la victimisation des combattants ce
qui n'est pas faux ils ont énormément
souffert dans leur chair dans leur
esprit s'agit pas de remettre ça en
cause mais on passe à mon avis à côté de
la vraie réflexion de ce que devrait
être ce centenaire sur la notion de
consentement de la société à la guerre
l'acceptation par la populace volume ans
et on touche là au vrai coeur du
problème
mais puisqu'on voit un jeune qui dit moi
si elle a guère j'y vais pas oui tout à
fait donc et ça devrait aussi une
réflexion plus globale sur la fragilité
de la paix sur ces engrenages qui ont
conduit conduit au suicide des nations
en 1914
donc à mon sens et qui va recommencer
vingt ans plus tard quand avec le
nazisme avec la seconde guerre mondiale
et puis là 50 millions de morts la
commune comme si on n'avait pas tiré les
leçons quoi tout à fait donc la
commémoration trop empreinte de
compassion une victimisation fait qu'on
passe à côté du vrai sens et de
l'analyse de l'événement et on va rester
sur cette ces derniers propos merci
madame merci messieurs d'avoir participé
à cette émission donc fin de cette
émission consacrée au 11 novembre 1918
merci de votre attention
bon dimanche après midi à tous au revoir
[Musique]